las dos partes coinciden en que la
última charla entre joe biden y xi
jinping fue profunda y sincera es la
misma fórmula que utilizaron para las
cuatro anteriores lo cual parece
solidificar la tendencia aumenta la
tensión por lo que eeuu entiende como
apoyo de china rusia o por lo que china
entiende como una aproximación de eeuu a
taiwán y antes de que las tensiones se
desborden los dos presidentes descuelgan
el teléfono hoy la prensa china ha
recuperado cierta tranquilidad después
de una semana encadenando editoriales
inflamados por el presunto viaje de
nancy pelosi a taiwán el 'global times'
el diario más sultán nacionalista de
todos aprobé que los dos presidentes
mantengan abiertas las líneas de
comunicación pero también deja un par de
recados a eeuu dice que la fuente de los
problemas es la falta de concordancia
entre las palabras bienintencionadas de
eeuu y sus acciones y como ejemplo
recuerda que en el mismo día de la
charla presidencial eeuu estaba
apadrinado en australia una conferencia
con representantes militares de 26
países del pacífico
también pide a estados unidos que frene
de una vez por todas lo que considera
como movimientos radicales en taiwán
sostiene que si la tensión vuelve a
escalar otra vez que será culpa
únicamente de eeuu y apela a su
responsabilidad como gran potencia para
preservar la paz